hi there Steve Kaufman here um first of
all if you enjoy these videos please
subscribe today I'm going to talk about
mastering the basics how do we master
the basics the basics of grammar the
basic vocabulary and the answer is we
don't in my opinion we gradually
gradually get used to them and the words
and the rules of grammar and the correct
structure are so fleeting so difficult
to grasp
they're almost like fireflies you see
them and then you don't see them you get
them right then you get them wrong I
haven't been doing much Russian I go
back to speaking Russian I'm looking for
words my case endings are worse than
they ever were and it's not surprising I
was speaking to a young man who has had
the French here in Vancouver for 12
years
in fact in French immersion and we were
speaking in French and he said je t'ai
says oh now in French you you have javi
says ah I had 16 years not I was 16
years now it's not surprising that he
says that because when we learn a
language we're having to superimpose new
habits on existing habits if we had no
habits there it would be easier you'd
come across you know Jay says on Java
says huh I have all right had 16 years
and that's just how it said that's fine
and dandy but you're superimposing that
on a habit that you have which is very
very strongly ingrained when we're
learning new words and phrases we're
having to replace existing patterns it
takes a lot of exposure a lot of
exposure and so one shouldn't be
disappointed when you forget things and
I constantly refer to this forgetting
and relearning and forgetting and
relearning that is all part of gradually
becoming accustomed to the new language
and that's why I have to laugh I was
looking
again trying to get into duolingo I just
cannot subject myself to do a link are
going to write a little article about it
on my blog but sorry is doing some
research on what people think of
duolingo and came across this study that
duolingo commissioned which said that 30
hours on duolingo was equivalent to one
year language study at a university now
how can they possibly make a statement
like that which language which
university which learner which learner
on duolingo which learner at a
university and you know and the test was
the course of multiple choice so yeah
you can get stuff right on a multiple
choice but does that mean that in the
future when you go to use these words or
use this grammatical pattern that you're
going to use correctly not necessarily
and so 30 hours on duolingo in terms of
exposure to the language is is really
nothing they tell you 5 hour 5 minutes a
day 5 minutes a day how long does it
take to get 30 hours lots you know even
if you did an hour a day that's 30 days
so you know whatever 12 12 times 12 a
year a year you get to 30 hours I'm
doing the math in my head here but um
that's nothing 30 hours is nothing if I
look at what I've done in Greek I've
listened to gosh I think I've listened
an hour a day over the last three months
I've listened 100 hours and I've spent I
don't know how many maybe another 50
hours reading and saving and reviewing
stuff like that and still it's only
gradually coming to me and sometimes
it's there and sometimes I don't have it
and so you don't master I've often said
this language learning is not a matter
of you know building blocks or bricks
that you build this solid thing it's
more a matter of of immersing yourself
and letting the brain develop some new
habits that are going to be superimposed
on habits that you already have habits
that you have for other languages so I'm
saying this because I just want to
debunk the idea
we can master the basics you know and
that you know you learn in 30 hours on
duolingo you learn more than a
university course all you're doing is
getting some exposure to the language
and I highly doubt that the exposure on
duolingo and a very artificial
environment where you're simply you know
translating or doing dictation or
answering multiple-choice questions but
that is as effective as massive
listening and reading which is gradually
going to make your brain become
accustomed to the language and and the
other thing is it doesn't matter like
I'm going to be in two weeks I'm going
to Bratislava so I want to kind of
refresh my check so there can be all
kinds of stuff missing in my check but
it doesn't matter like the check is
always going to be there and
Czechoslovakia or Czech Republic
Slovakia whatever it's not going away
all the stuff that I have all the books
and the material that I have in Lincoln
the stories in the audio it's always
there I can go back to it um I'm going
to meet people I'm going to speak with
them I'll enjoy the language I'll make
mistakes or I won't make mistakes or
I'll make more or fewer mistakes it
doesn't matter I'm just going back to
you know picking up with an old friend
doing something that I enjoy doing I'm
not there to to demonstrate my prowess
so one needn't be worried about the fact
that so much of what we learn in
language is fleeting and we continue to
get it wrong and we get it right for a
long time then we don't you know do
anything in that language for a while
and we start making more mistakes none
of that really matters the languages are
there to be enjoyed period so you know I
just want to talk a bit about the
fleeting nature of much of what we learn
but through it all gradually we get
better gradually we develop better and
better habits if we get enough exposure
so that is not entirely sure why I
wanted to make that point but I I kind
of felt that as I was getting back into
my check and realizing that when I go to
Bratislava I'm not going to be doing as
well as I did some years ago when I was
coming off a solid year of checking and
then held up seven days in Prague
but it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
it's something that I've added to my
repertoire of things that I can go to
whenever I want I can go back to my
Romanian I can go back to my German and
and enjoy it and as I get back into it
I will gradually improve again so thank
you for listening
bye for now
[Music]